a man learns his fate for leaving the
scene of a deadly crash but as Victoria
Saha explains it was an anonymous tip
that led police to find the person
responsible
day in court for the victim's family but
they say despite the sentence it took
one person to call in a tip for an
arrest to be made the family of 24 year
old Bailey Smith packed into the
courtroom Monday morning to face
37-year-old Adam farias Bailey wasn't
just the case number maybe it was a
human being
was a great kid Smith was riding his
motorcycle on Flamingo and Sandhill this
past September when he was hit the
driver did not stop judge Michael vilani
it's our duty
Smith died a few days later but during
this time an anonymous tip came into
Crime Stoppers of Nevada from Julia
Barnett she caught farius talking about
the crash at a gas station I heard him
talking to some other guys that were in
there that he had just recently got in
an accident and somebody got hurt and
there's a motorcycle and it was just
poor sporadic and then then I seen it on
the news and I put two and two together
I apologize for my actions and leaving
this in an accident I was scared and I
just didn't understand what's going on
is reacted Furious was sentenced to two
to five years in prison I don't wish for
mercy on her soul because he doesn't
have one although it doesn't ease the
pain for Smith's mom Kelly Norton it
does help to know farius was caught if
it wasn't for Julia calling it in
we made not avocado an example of how a
tip to Crime Stoppers can never be too
big or too small closure is very
important to families and we help to
bring that to them
and really a great reminder as Victoria
pointed out to always keep your eyes and
ears open you can report tips to Crime
Stoppers and be eligible to get a reward